Last time we made the turn from
metaphysics to value theory and we started
asking about what it is about
death that makes it bad.
The first aspect of the badness of death
that we talked about was the fact that
when somebody dies that's hard on the
rest of us were left behind having to cope
with the loss of this person
that we loved. Nonetheless,
it seems likely that if we want to get
clear about the central badness of death,
it can't be a matter of the loss
for those who remained behind,
but rather the loss, the badness
of death for the person who dies,
that any rate is what I want
to focus on from here on out.
What exactly is it about my death or the
fact that I'm going to die that makes
that bad for me.
Now want to get clear about precisely
what it is we want to focus in on here.
Now,
one thing that could be bad obviously is
the process of dying could be a painful
one. It might be, for example,
that I get ripped to pieces
by Bengali tigers and if so,
then the actual process of dying,
it would be horrible.
It would be painful and clearly it
makes sense to talk about the process of
dying is something that could
potentially be bad for me,
although similarly I
might die in my sleep,
in which case the process of dying
would not be bad for me. At any rate,
I take it that most of us though we might
have some passing concerned about the
possibility that our process of dying,
my pay painful one,
that's not the,
again,
the central thing we're concerned about
when we face the fact that we're going
to die.
It's also true,
of course it many of us find here right
now, while we're not actually dying,
the prospect of dying to be unpleasant.
So one of the things that's bad about my
death for me is that right now I've got
some unhappy thoughts as I anticipate
the fact that I'm going to die.
But again,
that can't be the central bad thing.
That's central thing that's bad about
death because it the prospect of my death,
it makes sense for that to be a
painful one or an unpleasant one.
Only given the further claim that death
itself is bad for me having fear or
anxiety or concern or a Greg or anguish
or whatever it is that maybe I have now
about the fact that I'm going to die
piggy backs on the logically prior thought
that death itself is bad for me.
If it didn't piggyback in that way
wouldn't make any sense to have fear or
anxiety or dread or anguish or whatever
it is that I may have now. I mean,
suppose I said to you tomorrow something's
going to happen to you and that thing
is going to be simply fantastic.
Absolutely incredible.
Absolutely wonderful. And you said, well,
I believe you and I had to tell you,
I'm just filled with dread and
foreboding in thinking about it.
Well that that wouldn't
make any sense at all.
It makes sense to be filled with
dread or foreboding, what have you.
Only if the thing you're looking
forward to anticipating is itself bad.
Maybe,
for example,
it makes sense to dread going to the
dentist if you believe that being at the
dentist is a painful,
unpleasant experience,
but if being at the dentist
isn't itself unpleasant,
it doesn't make sense to to dread
it in anticipation. So again,
if we're thinking about the
central badness of death,
it seems to me that we've got
to focus on my being dead.
What is it about my being
dead that bad for me?
Now,
if we pose that question,
it seems as though the answer should
be simple and straight forward.
When I'm dead, I won't exist.
Now previously, you know,
the first part of the class,
we spent some time saying
they look on certain views.
There'll be a period of time
in which you might be dead,
but your body might still be
alive or you might be dead.
But even though your body's still exist,
it's not alive,
but you exist as a corpse.
Put all that aside.
Go to the period beyond any of that,
that that murky stuff in the short term.
And just for simplicity,
let's suppose with the
physicalist that once I die,
I cease to exist.
All right,
so don't we have the answer to what's bad
about death right there when I'm dead,
I won't exist.
Isn't that the straight forward
explanation about why death is bad?
Now what I want to say in effect is this.
I do think the fact that I won't exist
does provide the key to getting clear
about how and why death is bad,
but I don't think it's quite straight
forward. I think as we'll see,
it actually takes some work to,
to to spell out exactly how death,
how nonexistence could be bad for me.
And even having done that,
there'll be some puzzles that remain that
will be turned into in a little while.
So the basic idea seems to
be straightforward enough.
When I'm dead,
I won't exist.
Isn't it clear that non-existence
is bad for me? Well,
immediately you get an objection.
You say,
how could nonexistence
be bad for me after all?
The whole point of nonexistence
is you don't exist.
How could anything be bad for you
when you don't exist doesn't it isn't.
They'll kind of logical requirement
that for something to be bad for you,
you've got to be around two
to receive that bad thing.
A headache, for example,
can be bad for you,
but of course you exist
during the headache.
Headaches couldn't be bad
for people who don't exist,
they can't experience or have
or receive headaches. How could,
how could anything be bad for you when
you don't exist and in particular then
how could not existence be bad for
you when you don't exist? So it's not,
as I say,
altogether straight forward to see how
the answer death is bad for me because
when I'm dead I don't exist.
How that answers the problem as opposed
to simply focusing our attention on the
problem. How can
nonexistence be bad? For me,
the answer to this objection I think
is to be found in drawing a distinction
between two different ways in
which something can be bad for me.
On the one hand,
something can be bad for me.
We might say in an absolute robust,
intrinsic sense,
take a headache again or other,
some other kinds of pain of stubbing
your toe or getting stabbed or whatever,
whatever it is,
being tortured.
Pain is intrinsically bad.
It's bad in its own right.
It's something we want to
avoid for its own sake.
And those normal,
normal,
normally things that are bad
for you are bad. Intrinsically,
they're bad by virtue of the,
their very nature.
There's something about the way
they are that you don't want those.
They're bad in their own right.
But there's another way of something
being bad for you that it's easy to
overlook. Something can
be bad. Comparatively.
Something could be bad because of what
you're not getting while you get this bad
thing.
So it could be what the economists call
bad by virtue of the opportunity costs.
It's not that it's intrinsically bad,
it's bad because while you're doing this,
you're not getting something better. How
could, how could that be? Let's go. Let's,
let's have a simple example.
Suppose that I stay home
and watch something on TV.
Just so you know, uh, a deal or no deal.
I watched this on TV and I have a good
enough time. How could that be bad for me?
Well, in terms of the first notion of
bad something, dean, intrinsically bad,
it's not that it's a,
it's a pleasant enough way to spend a
half an hour or however long it shows.
On the other hand,
suppose what I could be doing instead
of watching a half an hour of television
is being at a really great party.
Then we might say the fact that I'm stuck
home watching television is bad for me
in this comparative sense.
It's not that it's in itself
an way to spend some time,
it's just that there's a better way
to spend time that I could be doing in
principle at least.
If only I'd gone if only I'd been invited.
If only I remembered what have you
and because I'm forgoing that better.
Good.
There's something bad.
Comparatively speaking about the fact
that I'm stuck at home watching TV,
there's a,
there's a lack of the better good.
A lack is not intrinsically bad,
but it's still a kind of
bad in this second sense.
To be lacking a good is itself bad for me.
Similarly,
suppose
I hold out two envelopes and I say pick
one and you open up the first one and
you pick the first one and you
open it up and say, hey look,
10 bucks isn't that good for me?
Well,
of course 10 bucks is intrinsically good
anyway. Both of them intrinsically good.
It's only good as the
means to buy something,
but it's sort of good fourth
having for its own right,
but or because of what it can get you,
but if unbeknownst to you the
other envelope had $1,000 in it,
then we can say,
look,
it's bad for you that you pick the
first envelope bad and what sense?
Because you would have been better
off had you pick the second envelope,
you would have been having more
good or a greater amount of good.
Well nonexistence can't be
bad for me in our first sense,
it can't be that nonexistence
is intrinsically bad
worth avoiding for its own
sake. That would only make sense if
nonexistence with somehow, for example,
painful. But when you don't exist,
you have no painful experiences.
There's nothing about non-existence in
and of itself that makes us want to avoid
it.
Nonexistent as only bad for me in this
comparative sense because of the lack.
When I don't exist,
I'm lacking stuff.
What am I lacking?
Well,
of course what I'm lacking is life and
more particularly still the good things
that life can give me.
So nonexistence is bad by virtue of the
opportunity costs that are involved.
Famously a WC fields,
uh,
on his tombstone says personally,
I'd rather be in Philadelphia, right?
What's bad about being dead is you don't
get to experience and enjoy any longer
the various good things
that life would offer us.
So nonexistence does point to
the key aspect about death.
Why is death bad? Because
when I'm dead, I don't exist.
But if we ask why is and how can be
the case that nonexistence is bad,
the answer is because of the
lack of the good things in life.
Because when I don't exist,
I am not getting the things that I could
have otherwise gotten if only I were
still alive.
Death is bad because it deprives
me of the good things in life.
This account is known as nowadays known
as the deprivation account of the evil
or badness of death for obvious reasons,
right?
The key thought is what the
central bad about death,
about nonexistence is that it deprives
you of the goods of life you might
otherwise be getting.
That's the deprivation account and it
seems to me that the deprivation account
basically has it.
Right?
Eventually I'll go on to argue that
there are other aspects of death that may
also contribute to its badness aspects
above and beyond the one that gets
focused on by the deprivation to count,
but still it seems to me the deprivation
account points us correctly to the
central thing about death that's bad.
What's most importantly bad about the
fact that I'll be dead is the fact that
when I'm dead, I won't be
getting the good things in life.
I'll be deprived of them.
That's the badness of death according
to the deprivation to count.
Now,
if we accept the deprivation account,
if we try to accept the
deprivation account,
we faced some further
philosophical puzzles,
puzzles that many people have thought
are sufficiently overwhelming that we,
despite the initial plausibility of the
deprivation account, have to give it up
first objection is this.
Look,
if something is true,
quite general point,
it seems about metaphysics
is something is true.
There's got to be a time when it's true.
If I,
if I make some claim about a fact,
there's gotta be a time when
that fact is true. Here's a fact.
Shelley's lecturing to you now
about the badness of death.
When is that facts true? When was that
factory? Well, you know, right now.
Now here's another fact Shelly
wants lecture to you about, uh,
the nature of personal identity.
When was that fact true? Well,
we can point to a period of perhaps
of a week or two last month when I was
lecturing to you about personal identity,
things that are facts can be
dated. All right? That seems right.
But if it is right,
then immediately we got a puzzle.
How could death be bad for me if death
was bad for me, that would be a fact. If,
if, if my death is bad for me, that
would be a factory to ask. Well,
when is that fact true? Might
say, well, it's not true now.
Death isn't bad for me
now. I'm not dead. Now.
Maybe death is bad for me when I'm dead,
but that seems very hard to believe. I
mean, when I'm dead, I don't exist. Right?
How could anything be bad for me
then surely you've got to exist.
So there's a puzzle about
dating the badness of death.
Now
it may be that this puzzle about time
and the date of the badness of death is
what Epicurus had in mind.
There's a passage that I'm going to read
to you in a moment from epicurious this,
this passage has, has puzzled people,
has puzzled philosophers ever since.
Epicurus seems to me putting his finger
on something puzzling about death though
it's difficult to pin down exactly
what it is that's bugging him.
So we're going to try it
interpretation or two. But first,
here's the passage from Epicurus.
So death,
the most terrifying of ILS is nothing
to us since so long as we exist,
death is not with us,
but when death comes,
then we do not exist.
It does not then concern either the
living or the dead. Since for the former,
it is not,
and the ladder are no more.
They say it's not altogether clear
what Epicurus is bothered by there,
but one possible interpretation is this
puzzle about the timing of the badness
of death. Death can't be bad
for me now because I'm alive.
Deaf can't be bad for me when I'm dead.
I am no more than how can
things be bad for me then?
But if death has no time
that which is bad for me,
and if anything, that's true. Any fact
has to have a time when it's true,
then the purported fact that death
is bad for me can't really be a fact.
All right,
how could we respond to this objection?
Well know, one way of course is to to
accept the objections. Hey, you're right.
That doesn't really bad for me,
and some philosophers have indeed
accepted that very conclusion.
Maybe Epicurus the most of us want to say,
no,
no death is bad for me, and so we
need a better answer to that. Oh yeah.
When is it bad for you?
Objection.
Two possible responses.
One possible response would be to
grab the bull by the horns and say,
death is bad for me.
Facts do have to be dated.
Let me tell you when it's bad for me.
The other possible responses to grab as
it were the other horn and say, you know,
death is bad for me and I
agree that I can't date it,
but you were wrong to assume that
all facts have to be datable.
There are some things that are
true that we can't put a date on.
Let's start with the second.
Could there be some things that are
true that we can't put a date on?
Well,
here's one I think maybe suppose
that on Monday I shoot John.
I wound him with the bullet
that comes out of my gun,
but it's not a wound
directly into his heart.
He simply starts bleeding and he believes
slowly so he doesn't die on Monday,
he's wounded and he's dying,
but he doesn't die on Monday.
On Tuesday, let's suppose that
I have a heart attack and I die.
John's still around bleeding,
but still around.
On Wednesday,
the loss of blood finally overtakes
him and John Dies. All right,
so I shoot him on Monday,
I die on Tuesday.
John Dies on Wednesday.
Now I killed John.
I take it, we're all in agreement
about that. If I hadn't shot him,
he wouldn't be dead. I killed
him. When did I kill him?
Did I kill him on Monday? The day I
shot him. Oh, that doesn't seem right.
He's not dead on Monday. How
can I kill him on Monday? Oh,
he died on Wednesday. Did I
kill him on Wednesday? Well,
how could that be? I don't even exist
on Wednesday. I dyed myself on Tuesday.
How can I kill him after I'm dead?
So I didn't kill him on Monday.
Didn't kill him. I've got her on
Wednesday. I didn't come on Monday.
Didn't kill him on Wednesday when
he dies. When did I kill him? Well,
you know,
maybe,
maybe the answer is there's no particular
time at all when I killed them,
but for all that it's
true that I killed him.
What makes it true that I killed him?
What makes it true that I killed him
is that on Monday I shot him and on
Wednesday he died from the wound.
That's what makes a true.
But when did I kill him?
Maybe we can't date that.
Okay,
suppose we can't.
If we can't,
then there are facts that you can't date.
Like the fact that I killed John.
If there are facts that you can't date,
maybe here's another one.
My death is bad for me. When does,
when does that true? Can't date it.
But for all that,
maybe it's true.
So maybe we shouldn't
accept the assumption of the
argument that all facts can
be dated.
Of course,
the thought that all facts can be dated
as a very powerful one and no doubt many
of you are going to go home and start
trying to come up with an adequate answer
to the question. You know, when
exactly didn't Shelly killed John and,
and cover the natural maybe that
you can even accept and any rate,
maybe we should accept the thought
that all facts can be dated,
in which case, if we're going to want
to insist that my death is bad for me,
we better be able to come up with
that date. Well, maybe we can.
When would it be plausible to
claim my death is bad for me?
Well, not now. I deaf can't be
bad for me now I'm not dead.
But it's not 100% clear that the
other alternative isn't acceptable.
Why not say my death is
bad for me when I'm dead?
After all,
when is a headache bad for me?
When the headache is occurring now
according to the deprivation of cowed,
the badness of death consists in
the fact that when you're dead,
you are deprived of the goods of life.
So when his death bad
for you during the time,
perhaps you're being deprived
of the goods of life.
Well, when are you deprived
of the goods of life?
When you dead?
When does the deprivation actually occur?
When you're dead. So perhaps we
should just say, well, you were right.
Epicurus is was epicurious his argument.
You were right.
Epicurus all facts have to be dated,
but we can date the badness of death.
My death is bad for me during the time
I'm dead because during that time I'm
deprived of,
I'm not getting the good things in life
that I would be getting if only I were
still alive.
Well,
that's a possible
response to the objection,
but of course it just immediately
raises a further objection.
How could it be that death is bad for me?
Then how could it be that death
is bad for me when I don't exist?
Surely I have to exist in order
for something to be bad for me.
Well, for that matter, for
something to be good for me,
don't you need to exist in order for
something to be good or bad for you?
Well,
this point,
our way to a different possible
interpretation of Epicurus is argument.
The argument would be a something
could be bad or for that matter,
good for you.
Only if you exist be when you're dead.
You don't exist. So see,
death can't be bad for you.
Put that up on the board.
Hey,
something can be bad for you.
Only
you exist.
B,
when you're dead,
you don't exist.
So inclusion,
see,
death can't be bad for you.
Yeah,
maybe that's the argument
that Epicurus had in mind.
Let's hear epicurious has the quote
from epicurious again. So death,
the most terrifying of ILS is nothing
to us since so long because we exist.
Death is not with us,
but when death comes,
then we do not exist. It does not then
concern either the living or the dead.
Since we're the former, it is not.
And the ladder are no more. Again,
the passage from Epicurus
isn't off together. Clear,
but maybe he's got in mind something like
this argument. Maybe Epicurus thanks.
Look a,
something can be bad for you.
Only if you exist be when you're dead.
You don't exist.
So see,
death can't be bad for you.
Okay,
well,
what should we say?
It's pretty clear that B is true.
When you're dead, you don't exist.
And so the conclusion,
see death can't be bad for you.
Looks like it's going to follow.
Once we accept a call a
the existence requirement,
something can be bad or for that
matter, good for you. Only if you exist.
That's the existence
requirement for bads and goods.
If we accept the existence requirement,
it looks as though we have to accept the
conclusion. Death can't be bad for you.
Yeah.
What should we say?
Maybe what we should say is reject the
existence requirement in the ordinary
case pains,
being blind,
being crippled, what have you.
Losing your job in the ordinary case,
things are bad for you when
you exist in the ordinary case,
in order to receive Bads,
you've got to exist,
but perhaps that's only the ordinary case.
It's not all cases.
Perhaps we should say look
for certain kinds of bads.
You don't need to even exist in order
for those things to be bad for you.
What kind of bags could be like that?
Well,
of course deprivation bads
would be exactly like that.
To lack something you don't need to exist.
Indeed.
The very fact that you don't exist might
provide the very explanation as to why
you've got the deprivation,
why you've got the lack.
Not all lax might be like that,
right?
Remember the television case you existed
while you were being deprived of the
great party you existed while you were
getting the mirror $10 instead of the
thousand dollars. So sometimes
deprivations coincide with existence,
but the crucial point about deprivations
is you don't even need to so much as
exist in order to be
deprived of something.
Existence guarantees that
you're deprived of something.
So perhaps we should just reject
the existence requirement.
Perhaps we should say when
we're talking about lax,
when we're talking about
deprivations a is wrong,
we should reject the
existence requirement.
Something can be bad for
you even if you don't exist.
The existence requirement is false.
Well,
that would be a possible
way to respond to this.
The second possible interpretation
of Epicurus is argument.
It would be a way to retain
the thought that I take it.
We want to have that most of us share,
at least that death is bad by we'd be
able to retain that thought by rejecting
the existence requirement.
Well,
easy to save that,
but there are some implications
of rejecting the existence
requirement that may
be rather hard to swallow.
Think about exactly what it's saying.
It's saying something. For example, death.
Not Existence can be bad for somebody
even though they don't exist.
That's why my death can be bad
for me even though I won't exist.
But if death can be bad for somebody,
even though they don't exist,
then death could be bad for somebody that
has to say not existence could be bad
for somebody who never exists.
Take somebody who is a possible person
but never actually gets born.
Sort of hard to think about
somebody like that. So let's,
let's try to get at least a little bit
more concrete. I need two volunteers.
I need a male volunteer from
the audience. Good. Okay.
You'll be the male volunteer
and I a female volunteer
from the audience. Mine won't hurt.
You're the female volunteer. Okay.
What I'd like you to do after class
is go have sex and have the baby.
Okay.
Now
let me just suppose that this
isn't actually going to happen.
Sorry. And or sorry. I don't know. Uh,
let's,
let's consider though the possibility
never to be actual ISED the possibility
that they would have sex and have a baby.
You know,
his sperm join with her egg
form a fertilized egg. The,
the, the, the fertilized
egg develops into a fetus.
The fetus is eventually born.
It's,
it's the fetus that we got by mixing,
you know,
egg 37 with sperm 4 million,
309.
There's a person that
could have been born,
but let's suppose never does get born.
That particular person
who could have been born.
Let's call Larry.
Okay,
Larry is a possible person.
Could happen but won't happen.
Could exist,
but won't exist.
Now,
how many of us feel sorry for Larry?
Probably nobody after all,
Larry never even exists.
How can we feel sorry for Larry.
Now that made perfect sense when we
accepted the existence requirement.
A something can be bad
for you only if you exist.
Since Larry never exists.
Nothing can be bad for Larry,
but once we give up on
the existence requirement,
once we say something can be bad for you,
even if you never exist,
then we no longer have any grounds for
withholding our sympathy from Larry.
We can say,
oh my gosh,
think of all the goods in life that Larry
would have had if only he'd been born,
but
he never is born so he's deprived of all
those goods and if death is bad for me,
by virtue of being deprived of the goods
of life than nonexistence is bad for
Larry by virtue of his being deprived
of all the goods for of life.
Okay,
I got it bad, I'm going to
die. Larry's got it worse.
We should really feel
much Saria for Larry,
but I bet none of you
feels sorry for Larry.
This never to be born at all person.
That's important in thinking about this,
that we not slip back into
some version of the soul view,
especially some version of the soul view
where the soles are prior existence.
You know, you might imagine there's
a scene in homer I think where,
where uh,
some sort of sacrifices being made and,
and all the dead souls,
ghosts sort of hover around
longing to be alive again to,
to, to save her the, the, the food
and tastes and smells of life, right?
If you've got this picture
of the nonexistent merely
potentially possible but
never to be born individuals as somehow
really already existing in a kind of
ghost like state wishing they were born.
Maybe you should feel sorry for them,
but that's not what the story is at all.
I'm the physical list picture
that I'm assuming nonexistent.
People don't have a kind of
spooky wish I were alive.
Ghostlike existence.
They just don't exist full stop.
So once we keep that in mind about Larry,
it's very hard to feel sorry for him.
Of course.
Look,
since I've been going on about how he's
deprived of all the good things in life,
maybe some of you are
feeling sorry for Larry.
So it's worth getting clear about just
what it would mean to take seriously.
The thought that it's bad
for merely potential people.
Never to be born.
How many merely potential
people are there?
I need to get a sense of
just how many there are.
It's not just Larry,
the unborn person that would exist if
we mixed whatever it was, you know,
egg 37 and sperm 4 million in
29 whatever the number was,
not just Larry, who's a potential
person who never gets born.
That would have to be an
object of our sympathy.
There's a lot of merely
potential never to be born.
People. How many? A lot.
How many, well, I once
tried to calculate, well,
as you'll see, that calculation is
utterly off the back of the envelope,
sort of rough, uh, and, and completely
inadequate in ways that I'll, I'll,
I'll point out,
but at least it'll give you a sense of
just how many potential people there are.
Let's start modestly and ask how
many possible people could we,
the current generation
produced. Now, as I say,
I made this calculation some years ago.
Doesn't really matter
how inaccurate it's
going to be as we'll see.
It's very rough,
but it makes the point
how many people are there?
How many possible people rather,
could there be well smells.
There were 5 billion people,
roughly half of them are men.
Half of them are women.
What we want to know then is how many
possible people could the two and a half
billion men make out together with
the two and a half billion women.
And the crucial point in thinking about
this is to realize that every time you
combine a different egg
with a different sperm,
you end up with a different person,
right?
If you combine an egg
with a different sperm,
you get a different genetic code that
develops into a different person.
You combine that sperm with a different
egg, you get a different person.
You know, if, if, if,
if my parents had had sex five
minutes earlier or five minutes later,
presumably some other sperm
would have joined with the egg,
that would have been not me being born,
but some sibling being born.
Instead of me changed the egg, change
the sperm, you get a different person.
So what we really want to know is how
many sperm egg combinations are there with
roughly 5 billion people in the world?
Well,
let's see.
It's 2.5 billion women,
okay,
billion women.
How many eggs can a woman have?
Well,
fertile periods,
round numbers,
not really going to matter
position roughly 30 years, roughly.
12 eggs a year.
That's how many eggs
actually I discovered some time after
having done this calculation that the
number of possible eggs is far greater.
A woman actually oxalates and gives
off this many eggs roughly during her
fertile period,
but there's many,
many other cells I gathered that could
have developed into eggs touch a much,
much larger number of potential eggs,
but this will do 30 years.
12 eggs a year.
How many men? Roughly? 2.5 billion men
each man has. It has a much longer period
in which he's able to produce sperm.
Let's just be round numbers here.
50 years.
How many times a day can the man have sex?
Well,
certainly more than once, but let's be
a modest here and just say once a day,
so that's 365 times a day.
A year.
You want to 65 days a year.
65 days.
I guess that should be.
I wrote a too big, I don't have
space left for the last number.
Each time demand ejaculates
he gives off a lot of sperm.
How much sperm?
A lot is.
It happens, you know, look
this up. Once round numbers,
40 million sperm each time,
the and Jackie plates.
So this last number has got to be
times 40 million sperm.
Okay,
so we took all the men that exist now
and all the women that exist now and ask
how many merely possible people,
you know,
most of these people are never
going to be born of course,
but we're talking about possible people.
How many possible people are there?
It's two and a half billion times,
30 times 12 times two and a half billion
times 50 times 365 times 40 million.
That equals,
I'm going to round here.
That equals approximately 1.5
million
billion,
billion people.
That's 1.5 times 10 to the 33rd
that's how many possible people we
could have roughly speaking in the next
generation of which obviously a
minuscule fraction are going to be born.
There's,
if you're going to feel sorry for Larry,
you've got to feel sorry for
every merely possible person,
every person who could have been born
that never gets born and there's 1.5
million billion,
billion,
billion such people as possible people,
and of course the truth of the matter is
we've barely scratched the surface here
because now think of all those people
and think about all the possible children
they could have.
We got this number starting with a mirror,
5 billion people.
Imagine the number we would get if
we then calculated how many possible
grandchildren we could have.
I don't mean that we could actually
have of those people at the same time,
but for each one there is a possible
person that could have existed.
You quickly end up with
more possible people.
Then there are particles
in the known universe
and that was just two generations.
Three generations are going
to have more for generations.
You could have more as if we think
about the number of possible people,
people who could have
existed but will never exist.
The number of just boggles the mind and
then if we say we've gotten rid of the
existence requirement,
and so things can be bad for you,
even if you never actually exist,
then we have to say of each and every
single one of those billions upon billions
upon billions upon billions upon billions
of possible people that it's a tragedy
that they never get born because
they're deprived of the goods of life.
If we do away with the
existence requirement,
then the tragedy of the unborn
possible people is a moral tragedy.
That mirror that just staggers the mind.
The the worst possible moral horrors of
human history don't begin to even be in
the same ballpark as the
moral horror of the loss,
the deprivation for all of
these unborn possible people.
Now, I don't know about
you when I think about it.
All I can say is it doesn't strike
me as being a moral catastrophe.
I don't feel anguish and sorrow
and dismay at the loss at the LAC,
at the deprivation for the untold
billion, billion, billion, billions.
But if we give up the
existence requirement and
explained the badness of my
death via the deprivation account,
okay,
we do have to say
this is a moral tragedy.
The fact that they,
the billions upon billions are never born.
Well, if we're not prepared
to say that's a moral tragedy,
well, we could avoid that by, by, by
going back to the existence requirement.
But of course, if we do go back
to the six inch requirement,
then we're back with
Epicurus his argument.
Something can bad for you only if you
exist when you're dead, you don't exist.
So see,
death can't be bad for you.
Okay?
And how we really got ourselves in
a philosophical pickle, don't we?
Okay.
If I accept the existence requirement,
we've got an argument that
says death isn't bad for me,
which is really rather surprising.
I can keep the claim that death is
bad for me by giving up the existence
requirement. But if I give
up the existence requirement,
I've got to say it's a tragedy
that Larry and the untold billions,
billions, billions, billions,
it's a tragedy that they're
deprived of life as well.
And that seems unacceptable.
What should we do?
What should we say?
The suggestion is that the,
the key here is to think about the
claims that I'm using deprived in two
different senses,
that when we worry about my death,
I'm losing something,
namely life that I've had,
but in the case of a Larry
and the untold billions,
they never had life and so
they're not deprived of it.
In that same sense,
I think it's a very promising
suggestion and indeed I'm not 100% sure.
I've got exactly where you
want to go with this in mind,
but I think there's a way of taking that
thought and sort of carving a middle
path.
The problem effectively it was this,
if we don't throw in any
existence requirement,
we have to feel sorry for the
unborn billion, billion, billions.
That doesn't seem acceptable.
If we throw in the existence requirement,
a something can be bad
for you only if you exist.
We end up saying death isn't bad for me
cause I'm not existing when I'm dead,
but maybe there's a more modest way of
understanding the existence requirement
or to put the point in
slightly different terms.
Maybe we can distinguish between two
different versions of the existence
requirement,
a boulder and a more modest version.
Let's see.
Here's the modest version.
Something can be bad for you
only if you exist at
some time or the other
bolder claim.
Some things can be bad for you
only if you exist
at the
same time
as that thing.
All
right.
These are two different
ways of understanding what
the existence requirement
requires.
The modest version is called
modest because it's asking less.
It says something gave me dad for you.
Only if you exist at
some time or the other.
The bold existence requirement
adds a stronger requirement.
Says something can be bad for you only
if you exist at the very same time as the
thing that's supposed to be bad for you.
There's gotta be a kind of simultaneity.
Something's bad for you.
You had better exist at the very same
time that that bad thing is happening.
That's bolder than the modest requirement.
The modest acquirement doesn't require
that you exist at the same time as the
bad thing.
It only requires that you exist
at some time or the other.
One more minute we'll finish up.
Okay.
Suppose we accept the bold claim.
For something to be bad for you,
you have to exist at the very
same time as the bad thing.
Then death can't be bad for you because
you don't exist at the time of death.
Suppose however that we accept the modest
requirement for something to be bad
for you, you have to exist at
some time or the other. Well,
since I do exist at some time or the
other after all, I exist right now.
Yeah.
Death can be bad for me.
Admittedly,
I won't exist when I'm dead,
but that's okay.
The modest existence requirement,
does it require that I exist at the
very same time as the bad thing?
The bold one did,
but the modest one doesn't.
So the modest one allows us to say
that death is bad for me. But notice,
and this is the crucial point,
it does not say that non-existence is
bad for Larry because Larry never exists
at all.
And so he doesn't even satisfy
the modest existence requirement.
In short,
with no existence requirement,
we have to say the unexisting once
of the billions and billions is bad.
That seems unacceptable with
the bold existence requirement,
we have to say death isn't even bad
for me. That seems unacceptable.
But if instead we accept the
modest existence requirement,
we're able to say,
nonexistence is not bad for Larry,
but death is bad for me.
And so that's the view that it seems
to me we should be looking at. Okay.